je pense qu'alain chabat il veut un
comedy voilà alors rappelez vous le nom
de camille combal a été évoqué
rapidement démentie et alain chabat a
dit moi vivant camille combal ne
présentera jamais burger quiz un nos
jours les gens qui passent par ci aux
oreilles un nom qui circule
c'est un animateur c'est un comédien on
le connaît bien il est déjà venu sur ce
plateau
bien sûr ces huit noms mais il a
présenté une émission sur canal + avant
la cérémonie des césars la dernière
séquence d'âge et de manu payet et manu
payet noms circulent pour présenter
potentiellement les futures saisons de
burger quiz alors bonne idée ou pas le
be alors des drôles flegmatique trash
second degré c'est vraiment l'humour des
nuls moi je trouve qu'il y avait pas
telle qu'elle est ce qu'il ya c'est une
bonne idée je suis pas trop fan moi si
j'étais suis la mieux je ne parle pas
son délire c'est là pas mieux à faire
renoncer le nigeria tient bon allez
c'est pour les césars il était excellent
c'est vrai ça serait manu payet le
serveur était très bonne ou mauvaise
idée manu payet vous nous dites en tout
cas c'est l'info de mathieu gallet vous
dites quoi très mauvaise idée il va rien
apporter franchement un petit peu comme
vous ici
[Rires]
[Applaudissements]